please join me you're welcome
thank you
alright thanks very much I am excited to
be here as part of this dedication for
the new gate Center it's an honor and
adds a privilege to have been involved
there's great number of people who made
this possible starting with Carnegie
Mellon President Jerry Cohen in CMU's
Board of Trustees their vision and their
support as well as the thoughts of
Professor guy Blaylock who traveled
across the country to gather ideas from
successful academic buildings to ensure
that both the gates and hellman centers
would meet the demanding goals laid out
clearly they did a great job and and we
see it before us today I'd like to
particularly thank Henry and Elise
Hillman for being essentially partners
together in getting this area to be so
fantastic a number of other people are
have been key to this including more
than 20 Microsoft employees and it's
really no accident that that came
together the link between Microsoft
Carnegie Mellon has always been very
strong and the list of distinguished
alumni and professors have been a key
part of Microsoft success as all so long
including Rick gratiot Anu Gupta Arnold
Bluhm and Harry Shum many of these
people provided significant donations to
help with the building and I know
they're thrilled to give back to CMU for
the important role it played in their
careers if anything the connection
between Microsoft and CMU is stronger
than ever they're working together on a
wide range of projects spanning some of
the most ambitious and exciting things
in all of computer science there's also
a strong foundation connection between
the Gates Foundation and CMU one of
those is that there's over a dozen gates
millennium scholars here and
I had a chance to meet with them and
talk about their great work earlier
today another example is a project on
learning this is the Carnegie Mellon
open learning initiative and I think
this is an amazing and critical piece of
work the idea is to use online
interactive material to adapt to the
student to see what the students
confused with so the student immediately
knows what their understanding and what
they're not so the teacher can see how
they're doing explaining the complex
concepts and dynamically adapt the in
classroom time to make sure that the
right things are covered also the course
itself by being online and measured can
be in a state of constant improvement
the idea of these virtual labs and
intelligent tutoring systems I think can
really revolutionize education and we
need to revolutionize education you know
today more than ever if we look at the
quality of education that most students
in this country received it's very very
poor the experience that you've had
before you came to CMU and of course
here at CMU itself is unfortunately the
exception rather than the rule and as we
think about technology and all the
things that's revolutionized you know
buying airplane tickets and looking at
DNA data I think it's perhaps most
amazing how little so far it's changed
the practice of education itself and yet
in terms of empowering people to achieve
their potential not just in the United
States but in the world as a whole
having great teachers having a great
education is one of the most critical
things we need going forward and so I
believe that by taking the work being
done here bringing it together with
videos the great professors bringing it
together with lots of data that analyze
what's going on in different school
systems making it freely available out
on the internet for constant improvement
I believe that at
education can be radically improved and
so any student wants to learn something
either in a classroom type environment
or in a purely online environment that
that should be possible and so it's
great to see the ambition taking place
in this particular project that the the
foundation is helping to fund right now
there are 40 community colleges that are
partnered with that project actually
putting these courses to work and making
their contributions to making them
better pioneering work in in computer
science of course has been going on here
for over half century and it was great
to see some of the highlights of the the
big bold contributions that have been
made I think this is going to not only
continue but accelerate the potential
for using computing particularly in some
of these cross disciplinary areas like
computational biology the promise is
greater than ever robotics is a
fantastic example of this whether it's
learning or vision speech recognition
mechanical modeling all of these things
really get pushed to the state of the
art and CMU has been a huge leader in
this and it was fun to meet one of CMU's
latest robots I was told that next time
I come it will give me a tour around the
building and it was very polite to me
and they said it would go get coffee for
me but we didn't actually try that out
so there's real progress being made you
know more and more ambition in fact if
we think of a lot of societal problems
in terms of health care you know an
elderly population many of these if we
think a decade and two decades out of
the role of robots in helping to deal
with those problems and continue to
improve the quality of life I think can
be very strong there's some amazing
people who do this robotics work
including red Whitaker man yella veloso
Mason and many others and we really
appreciate the connection that exists
between Microsoft who's also working on
robotics and very optimistic about these
things in the way the
we're working together on the Center for
innovative robotics and I think with the
right leadership we can bring everybody
in the world together to learn to try
and ambitious new things and I think
people will be very surprised at the
pace of progress in robotics you know
even very tough problems like being able
to help move a patient medicine you know
in 10 or 20 years I think it's very
possible that we'll have those things
language technologies will be another
area where you'd pick where Carnegie
Mellon has been very much out in front
even going back to the original hidden
Markov work that I was in 1974 the cut
this school has stayed at the forefront
of that with a lot of speech activity in
fact I think if you took any group at
microsoft said what had the highest
percentage CMU graduates that might be
our our speech recognition group and of
course the work here continues to push
the forefront turns out many of these
problems are much more challenging than
we thought and that makes them more
interesting more more fascinating and
there really is pretty incredible
progress I saw today a very clever
technique that's been used to help the
machine translation and gauge humans in
assisting to show how articles should be
translating and then that base of data
is there to help with the the Machine
approach that over time I think can be
very very good and we can look into the
future and expect that our cell phone I
will be able to talk to it you know ask
it questions tell it to schedule
something you know that's going to be
common sense and that I'd say is on an
even near term prize and perhaps in five
years certainly Microsoft Google many
others are putting that out for various
narrow applications today and there's
every reason to expect that'll get even
broader sorta midst of an incredible
transformation where computer science
including the work here is is sitting in
a central role and if you think about
well what's biology about a lot of it's
about analyzing DNA
protein expression and finding patterns
that only a rich software approach will
make possible now when we think about
learning computer sciences at the center
of that when we think about modeling new
materials we think about you know making
new vaccines all of those things
software element is is stronger than
before you know eventually with this
genomic data we will be able to solve
very top medical problems one of the
diseases I spend a lot of time learning
about and hoping that we can make
progress on is malaria today over a
million people a year die of malaria
that's mostly children in Africa malaria
at one time was spread almost over
almost the entire globe in fact even in
northern United States there was
mullerian there was a lot of malaria
down in the south well in fact
fortunately it didn't have a stronghold
as you got that far north and so the
invention of DDT is an insecticide and
the application that actually eliminated
it and we only think about malaria today
when we travel into those regions
unfortunately what that's meant is that
the focus of investing on that
particular diseases has been very low
but there's reasons to be optimistic
that advances in modeling drugs modeling
vaccines will will help us get there
also we're modeling the disease itself
techniques that come out of physics of
modeling actually let us look at various
factors like the types of vector and the
weather and understand what new tools
will need bed nets medicines in door
spring that will let us reduce the
malarial map very dramatically and so
you wouldn't normally make a connection
between malaria in those million lives
year and the need for advances in
software but in fact that connection is
very strong and you can expect to see a
great progress because of the kind of
technology that's worked on here also we
look at a top problem like
energy and I spent yesterday in
Washington DC at the Department of
Energy you know trying to understand the
sort of complex politics of various
things like a cap-and-trade bill but in
fact if you zoom out and think you know
how can we have it all how can we have
developing nations experience the kind
of lifestyles that we're used to have
our lifestyles advanced the fact is its
innovation innovation in material
science for solar thermal for solar
vocal the take modeling approaches for
new nuclear designs would be radically
different avoid some of those problems
and again we come back to computer
science and some of the very advanced
work going on it is very possible and
I'm optimistic to say it's likely that
over the next two decades will get
energy approaches that not just meet an
environmental constraint of not putting
out greenhouse gases but also that meets
the constraint to being less expensive
because the only way to help the poorest
is to bring the cost of energy down from
what it is today that's transport that's
fertilizer that's clean water it's the
empowerment for them to live the
lifestyles that we take for granted and
so they're the central role of
software's providing something that's
important so we're going to see some
great things in the years ahead some of
these advances are being developed here
at carnegie mellon right now others will
come along as we get new generations of
students here and this facility taking
advantage of what we're dedicating today
so I'm always inspired when I come here
I'm inspired by the great minds that are
here and the ones that will be coming
here and I'm inspired by the
opportunities to do work that's both fun
and interesting but also makes a big
difference not just in the United States
but to the world as whole as a whole so
I'll be following your work and I can't
wait to see these great advances that
are delivered in the the progress that
will enable thank you
so I'm pleased that Bill Gates is able
to answer some questions I ask that
people who want to ask questions and I
encourage you to do so to come up and
use these two microphones and we'll have
a session here right here
hi my name is Leanne sudol and I'm a PhD
student studying computer science
education and how people learn about
computers with the amount of great work
that your foundation does in terms of
bringing education to urban schools and
the less privileged children how do you
see computing literacy for our next
generation as they try and reach towards
Carnegie Mellon well certainly in rich
countries like the United States the
opportunity to use computers and be
familiar and comfortable with them and
to actually have them be a key part of
the educational processes really become
like reading literacy itself it's
something that we've got to make sure is
available to everyone our best ally in
doing that is that the price of
computers continue to come down and the
price of connectivity continues to come
down if you buy you know say a netbook
type computer for a couple hundred
dollars you're lucky enough to be in a
place with Wi-Fi access you know use
that computer over a number of years
particularly if it can avoid your having
to buy textbooks you're already at the
point where it's a net savings for the
students where are those four or five
textbooks you know we've got a little
more work to get that done but your net
ahead one of my favorite projects that
the foundation did was working with the
over 50,000 libraries in the United
States and helping to provide computer
hardware but not just the hardware the
right software in the training and when
we embarked on that we did a pilot
project down in Alabama we wondered if
the librarians would embrace it you know
this is a strange machine and you know
is it just kids coming in to do
something weird and you know how do you
deal with the thing it breaks and people
stand in line but in fact by really
learning and working with them we were
able to get an incredible reception in
fact it's really revitalized the
libraries in rural areas even more so
than in urban areas but in both I'd say
and so that's that's been very
successful in its been maintained over
time so the kid doesn't have his own
machine you know it's community centers
library school
is there ought to be ways that you can
get access and that's an important
threshold because it's only when we make
that assumption that these interactive
learning tools like the Carnegie Mellon
online initiative it's only then that
you can require those and actually you
know maybe reduce the time in class and
have have the interactive learning be
part of that so getting pervasive access
is is an enabling factor hi my name is
Thomas right I'm a freshman in the
School of Computer Science and this sort
of ties in with her earlier question how
do you feel about the open software are
the open-source software project and
what are some of your personal
experiences and that well clearly
there's been free software you know all
there's always been free software there
always will be free software and the
great thing about all marketplaces you
get this dynamic where you know somebody
wants to go off and start a company and
pay salaries for people that's good
thing they pay taxes create jobs and so
that software they have to make it
better than what it's ever free and be
able to charge for that you know
hopefully the people who use whatever
great work they do every once in a while
we'll pay them so they can pay their
salaries and then at the same time you
have things that are done for free you
know the original unique system done out
of Bell Labs was a free piece of
software and everybody you know looked
at that benefited from that there's
various descendants of that they're used
the original browser University of
Illinois piece of work was a free piece
of software now that never got much
usage because it was a small-scale team
that did it it was actually more larger
projects that came along later that
actually moved that thing for it so you
have a very positive emek it's a market
type system where depending on the
category of software you'll either have
the really expensive stuff the mid
expensive stuff that cheap stuff for the
free stuff will have different shares
you know if you go to a corporation and
look at the database they use they
typically use a fairly expense
piece of software for that if you go and
look at consumers and then you get more
down to the lower end so it's a very
healthy dynamic I do think that in time
you there won't it won't tilt in the
sense i do think that there will be jobs
working as a software person which will
be supported by the commercial element
that is part of this dynamic mix hello
hello I'm Paul software chemistry major
and gates millenium scholar which
actually leads me to my question uh how
do you go about you and Melinda of
course and also mr. Hellman go about
deciding like where and how much time to
dedicate to the philanthropies that you
do because there's a lot of causes out
there but at the same time you can't do
everything on time now that's an
excellent question and it's a troubling
question because when you first get into
philanthropy and people know that you
might write some checks there's no
shortage of stories from you know
individuals who are kind of down on
their luck or just you know a small loan
would be unbelievable out to very very
top problems and you know turn in terms
of magnitude that's pretty simple you
take whatever you think is appropriate
for your your kids to have which
certainly in my case is a percentage is
very small they haven't voted on that
but they won't get to vote on it they
may feel a little it's a little too
small but oh well and then the rest of
it you want to give back to society to
have the greatest possible impact and if
you look at the world at large and say
okay what what caught what global Clause
should you pick and I give you how I end
up taking global health and empowering
the pores the primary thing our
foundation goes after if you'd go back
to the 1960s the world was characterized
by very few rich countries that
represented less than a third of the
world and then the rest were very poor
countries and they were almost none in
the middle China was very poor India was
very poor everybody but parts of Europe
starting Japan in Western Europe Japan
the US Canada Australia and then if you
move forward to the year say 2000 it was
very different where you had about
two-thirds of the world was doing pretty
well was clearly on a positive cycle
without special help that the virtue of
the more educated you get the more
stable your society is the more you're
you're doing good products you know
countries like Brazil and Mexico that
back in nineteen sixty or
undistinguished from say sub-saharan
Africa actually pour in both cases that
most of sub-saharan Africa you know they
had moved up in a dramatic way China is
the most dramatic of all because of the
reforms that actually didn't start until
nineteen seventy nine but it's the
greatest creation of wealth the world
has ever seen in reduction and it's not
just economic it's you know in the 1960s
over 20 million children died every year
children under five died most recently
last year that numbers down to 8.8
million and so how do we go when the
bursts have gone up a lot because the
populations higher has gone up a lot how
do we more than reduce those deaths by
patra to its to only two things one is
as you get wealthier your food your
lifestyle your shelter is just better
and so you're less subject to disease
and the second is the miracle of
vaccines that have come in for something
like measles and and cured all those
lives so seeing in my view implants
because if you don't know any example or
something's worked in flat you were in
uncharted territory knew a few of those
but it's better to pick a paradigm
that's that's been successful and see
how you can catalyze more of that and in
the case of these poor countries won't
happen that graduated and became part of
the rich countries is I'm
mixture of good health a literacy and
reduction in population growth and the
strongest connection is as you improve
health it reduces population growth
which and it increased literally now
when I first saw that that was a paradox
because you think well if you make
people healthier than you get more
people right because you're avoiding
death so the answer is very quickly in
less than half a generation parents
adjust that is the fertility they drop
the fertility rate to more than
compensate way more than compensate for
the improvement of health and it's
actually well understood now that what's
going on is that in a household you're
having enough kids that even given the
uncertainty of health that you're going
to have two to three survived to be an
adult and so the more health problems
you have the more you have to get this
large number just have the insurance of
having the high probability of having
somebody to take care of you because you
don't have social security or anything
and that is why health is so catalytic
anyway and so I you know I decide okay
we'll go do health because you can save
lives in global health you can spend
less than a thousand dollars and you can
save a life you know air bags for
example very good thing that case you
spend 10 million dollars you save a life
you know so it's good we should do that
but the lives saved in that technique or
you know it's costing you 10,000 times
as much that is if you didn't spend that
money to say that one life you could
save 10,000 lives because these vaccines
aren't being produced and provided but
you know that hopefully will will get
fixed so that you know I in my case I
pick health and helping the poor as the
global problem and then I decided to
pick one problem and this was with my
wife Melinda totally one problem that
was in the United States which had
created the environment that allowed the
the wealth to be created and that was
education and that's where the online
learning and measuring teachers and
scholarships those things come out of
saying okay what one thing if you could
help it even a little bit
would make the future of this country
better than any other problem you could
work on in education with it we've had a
particular Liam's particular emphasis on
high school education is is what we've
chosen so that's a long answer to how
you decide to spend 30 billion dollars
in case any of you need to know yeah if
you have that problem all right Warren
Buffett had the same problem he made me
um my name is Joe and from China so um I
want to ask how do you feel about the
huge copyright issue in China like
illegal copies of software well I mean
pepper school business so well the the
issue of you know how intellectual
property should be priced it's gonna
it's a big issue it's gonna be around
for a long time you know I'm sure people
get my vaccines they don't know to say
we thank God somebody paid for software
but
when I started Microsoft the first big
sort of thing I got known for amongst
all these it was nobody was in this
business but there were these computer
clubs and I'd go around and visit the
computer clubs and I'd left the paper
tape around and so somebody took it
copied it so my first letter was called
an open letter to hobbyist that said hey
come on you guys quit ripping off my
paper tapes if you don't pay for the
stuff we can't write anymore and that
was my first and last you know kind of
outraged emotional statement about
copyright violation based on the
response to that I decided oh you've
never been upset about it is never
effective and you know for some products
you just have to figure out what the
price is that it's going to be
attractive to the market sometimes you
can do that sometimes you can't China
have you compared if you said at a
certain level of wealth people stop
copying software and said oh and
compared that about cross various
countries the richer country is the less
copy nerves it doesn't drop to zero you
know maybe there's some people here who
have music they didn't pay for I don't
know but it drops particularly in
business use it drops and in individual
use it never drops to zero but what's
unique to China's you have large
businesses using software without paying
for it super profitable large businesses
you know take two of the five most
profitable businesses in China they
don't pay for their sovereignty so
that's pretty that's a case where the
Chinese have done something quite unique
but I'm not complaining about it I'm you
know I'm a big fan of China and a lot of
great things
but you know we've all got things to
work on time for one more question sure
hi my name is Kevin on the sophomore in
school of computer science I first want
to thank you and the Hillman foundation
we're giving us a new home so this
question is from online a lot of people
wanted to ask about your philanthropy so
what is your opinion on modern Flannery
philanthropy today you think it's harder
to get people to donate well it's
especially in the light of the current
neck and on the state or do you think
it's actually a lot easier I definitely
think that it's tougher since the
financial crisis to get people to donate
now it's fantastic that the drop-off has
been less than I would have expected if
you give me this scenario of how much
how top things have been I would have
predicted more drop-off but it's a very
tough situation for a lot of foundations
because they have two sources of income
one is the current donations and those
have dropped off and the other is that
they often will have their endowment in
varying degrees in the stock market and
so of the top 20 foundations in the US
the average loss in the corpus was about
twenty eight percent over a one year
period we lost twenty percent so we're
really smart and now a lot of them have
gained some of that back but but nowhere
near all of it so you have both your
your corpus that you expected to
increase you people are kind of spoiled
by a lot of years there were thought
well you know is that a five percent ish
or fifteen percent and you're
particularly had a thing where there was
this jealousy effect which happens in
many systems where people looked at the
returns they Yale and Harvard had as
they were using exotic things well those
guys actually got incredibly above
normal returns for the exotic things
they did because they saw them before
other people then as other people rushed
in take ten
timberland up ridiculously miss price
but it was a faddish thing where that it
worked for Harvard at one price and it
was going to be a disaster for the other
so you had both this lemming effect and
the market as a whole being a problem so
you had a lot of foundations including
summit educational institutions where
they really what was hurt I didn't study
the CMU figures and had to cut back so
these are these are tough times for
foundations and they're trying you know
they're not used to having to cut back
and some are actually being pretty smart
about it and everything now is the US
economy is going to come back it could
take a while you know people like to
talk about the shape of the cover but
this country will keep creating wealth
why will it keep creating wealth because
of the things we've been talking about
the the new medicines and robots and you
know which country is by far going to be
doing these innovations for the future
our share of innovation may not be you
know what it was in 1948 say at the end
of World War two but it's still
extremely high China is increasing its
share which is a great thing for the
world the more innovation there is you
know when you get it life-saving drug
you don't say too many times it where
was that made again and so you know
we're we're going to get back on a good
track and so I think philanthropy will
get back on a good track and one of the
things I like to do is is share with
other people how much fun I'm having
giving the money away and trying to make
sure it's not not miss spent and you
know with the the subtext of boy I'd
love to have have more join in thank you
very much
you